most actors would probably love a chance
to score a role in HBO's Game of Thrones
and there have been plenty of A-list
celebs who have tried to get on the hit
series to no avail but there was a time
when that wasn't the case whether it was
because of the grueling overseas filming
schedule gripes with the cast pay scale
or sheer confusion over the George R.R
Martin inspired story here's a look at
some actors who refused Game of Thrones
roles
Tams and Merchants
where Emilia Clarke gained International
Fame as Daenerys Targaryen Tams and
Merchant was originally cast as the
mother of dragons for the show's
original unaired pilot the first version
of the pilot was according to
showrunners D.B Weiss and David benioff
a massive problem and 90 percent had to
be redone we had this great opportunity
when HBO decided to pick up the series
despite
all the problems with the pilot we got a
chance to go back and rewrite it when
HBO re-shot Merchant dropped out of the
project for unknown reasons and moved on
to Salem opening the door for Clark to
take over
Jennifer Ely Merchant wasn't the only
original Game of Thrones star to walk
away after its early problems Pride and
Prejudice star Jennifer Ely was also in
the original pilot playing Catelyn Stark
but she too walked away after the first
take spelled trouble due to
unavailability for the reshoots she went
on to star in films such as The King's
Speech The Adjustment Bureau and Zero
Dark Thirty she also nabbed a part in
the television series A Gifted Man so
her career hasn't really been heard by
her decision to skip out on the role
that ultimately went to Michelle Fairley
Jamie Campbell Bower
another actor featured in the original
pilot who had to drop out was Jamie
Campbell Bower the Twilight and Harry
Potter actor was originally cast for the
role of night's Watchman waymar Royce in
a scrapped pilot but became unavailable
once reshoots were scheduled around the
same time the actor was starring in the
small screen series Camelot and readying
for a lead role in The Mortal
Instruments so he was replaced by Rob OS
Leary it might not have made much of a
difference for his career anyway since
Royce was killed in the show's opening
scene maybe that was an omen
Brian Cox given his impressive resume
Scottish actor Brian Cox might seem like
a good fit for one of the Seven Kingdoms
and somebody on the show must have
agreed he admitted he was once offered a
role early on but turned it down over
the lack of loot he told vodzilla quote
stupidly I turned it down in the early
days because they didn't pay enough
money now they have more money and I was
silly I was silly it was silly because
I'm a complete addict now end quote Cox
admitted that he regrets missing out on
his chance especially since it's
featured some of his old friends he
hopes he hasn't closed the door on that
opportunity for good quote I don't know
what I could play maybe I could do I
mean I just watched my friend Ian
McShane and I thought ooh Ian's in it so
I settled down to watch him and I
thought Ian did that and immediately I
thought God they must have paid him well
because I know Ian I'm still waiting for
the call for Game of Thrones and if
they've got more decent money I'll be
there end quote hopefully they listen
because seriously no one wants to be on
the receiving end of an angry Brian Cox
and you my friend don't know crap about
life and why the are you wasting my two
precious hours with your movie
Dominic West
while it's not quite known Which Game of
Thrones role Dominic West was originally
courted for many suspect the affair star
may have been asked to appear as Mance
Raider the former Knights Watchman who
became known as the king Beyond the Wall
for his affiliation with the free folk
whatever the role though West told
Huffington Post in 2012 that he had to
decline the lovely part because of
family obligations quote I was offered
something on Game of Thrones and
unfortunately I hadn't seen it but my
nephew and his father said gosh Game of
Thrones is the only great show on and I
felt terrible because I just turned them
down it was a lovely part a good part
I'm going to regret it my problem is
I've got four kids and at the moment I'm
reluctant to be away from home for a
long time I can get a lot of work in
London and still be at home end quote
Jillian Anderson
X-Files star Jillian Anderson also had
to say no thanks to a chance at Game of
Thrones due to her obligations as a
parent she told stylus magazine in 2013
quote whether it's Game of Thrones or
Downton Abbey my 18 year old cannot
believe I've turned down things she
loves but with a four and six-year-old I
can't justify spending that kind of time
away from home unless I'm working with
Martin Scorsese end quote while Anderson
didn't share which role she might have
been offered many speculate that due to
her famous red locks she may have been a
match for Melisandre the Red Witch there
is someone I work with I like his name
is Jon Snow but I'm not really sure he's
the right guy why not
I'm pretty sure he's dead
Jonathan price
Game of Thrones fans will undoubtedly
recognize Jonathan price as the actor
who portrayed the duplicitous High
Sparrow in Seasons five and six but
believe it or not he was actually asked
to join the show long before that and
turned it down as he told BBC Radio 4
quote I'd said no to the very original
series of Game of Thrones and all I did
was flip through and look at the names
look on these strange names strange
dialogue and I thought oh it's not for
me end quote what changed his mind he
said was the high Sparrow's personality
and presence quote hi Sparrow it's a
great character he comes into the story
everyone's well established the goodies
and the baddies and they're all baddies
in some shape or form and High Sparrow
comes in as again quite relevant because
of the present Pope who presents himself
as a man of the people who will get down
washing their feet and stuff yet he is
this incredibly powerful figure who has
the wherewithal to dispense Justice end
quote her data weeks
this one simply has to hurt the Tudors
and Penny Dreadful actress perdita weeks
was originally cast to Star as Rosalind
Frey edmure Tully's wife but she backed
out because her commitment to another
series called the Heretics required her
to be on location in Romania for six
months one problem the Romanian
government refused to let them film and
the whole show got scrapped anyway weeks
told the Daily Mail in 2012 quote I gave
up a role on Game of Thrones to take the
part and even rang the producers to beg
for it back once I'd heard the news
about Romania but it was too late end
quote the role was ultimately played by
Alexandra Doling although weeks might
not have missed out on much the
character has appeared in just one
episode and was notably absent when her
husband returned in season six
Ray Stevenson
Irish native Ray Stevenson was also
given a chance to star in Game of
Thrones in its earliest episodes but he
told movies.com that he turned it down
because he was simply not into the TV
scene at the time and that he's not
willing to join it now since it's
already two developed at this point
quote I was offered a role I also saw
them before they even started very early
on I would rather have been cast at the
beginning I think it's wonderful but
it's not something I would come into at
this point I don't know if I would add
anything to it at this stage I would
rather have been involved in the growth
of a show Even though everyone gets
bumped off left right and Center I kept
seeing all the people I knew from Rome
in it but I can't man I can't end quote
given that Stevenson joined both Dexter
and Black Sails in progress though it's
possible he could still change his mind
Lily Allen
according to singer Lily Allen she
turned down the chance to star in Game
of Thrones opposite her real-life
brother Alfie Allen she would have been
Yara gray joy to his Theon because of
the ick Factor associated with the rules
she wrote in a Reddit AMA in 2014 I've
been asked to do a Game of Thrones Cameo
they asked me if I'd be interested in
playing theon's sister and I felt
uncomfortable because it would have had
to go on a horse and he would have
touched me up and once they told me what
was entailed I said no thanks then again
she may have been pulling the internet's
leg that time her brother himself later
came forward to dispel her claim telling
vulture that her words were true and
that Gemma Whalen was always the
original choice for the role
Landing a role in a Marvel movie means
potential stardom for up-and-coming
actors renewed popularity for aging vets
and a fat paycheck for anyone willing to
Don a cool metal Spirit but despite
Marvel's impact on the modern movie
business not every actors came to put on
a mask and do battle with alien armies
here are a few actors who refused big
Marvel roles Ross and Crowe these days
Marvel movies are guaranteed to bring in
big numbers at the box office but before
the year 2000 that wasn't necessarily
the case fortunately things started to
change for Marvel when Brian singers
X-Men first hit the big screen it's
credited as the film that gave rise to
the modern era of superhero movie and
transformed Hugh Jackman from a stage
performer into a Hollywood a-lister but
according to the actor it was pure like
he got the part in the first place at
one point the filmmakers turned to Russ
and Crow to play Wolverine who was fresh
off the set of gladiator however Crow
turns apart down for a reason that's
well a little weird I've just done a
character who's uh you know animal totem
was the wolf that fellow Max and
Gladiator to want to be connected to a
wolf again of course Crow further
clarified his reasoning and plus it's
the cartoon it was a cartoon and I'm not
really into those yeah but that didn't
really stop him from appearing in Man of
Steel luckily for superhero fans
everywhere he did recommend that Brian
Singer go with you Jackman food
previously auditioned for the part
Matt Damon as hard as we tried no one
can forget 2003's dead up while the Ben
Affleck flick did well financially
critics tore it apart when asked about
the film in 2016 Affleck responded
there's a hated Daredevil so much you
know what I mean I mean no you know I
did okay don't feel bad for me turns out
that Affleck could have been spared all
that embarrassment if his best friend
had accepted the role first Matt Damon
was offered the part of Daredevil and it
was a pretty tempting deal Jin's diamond
and Affleck considered dead him to be
their favorite superhero but when Damon
was approached with the project
reportedly he just wasn't impressed with
the script both familiar enough with the
director Affleck couldn't say no and has
come to regret that decision but at
least Daredevil's failure inspired him
to get his next superhero movie right
Joseph Gordon-Levitt over the years
there have been a lot of whispers about
Joseph Gordy Levitt in the Marvel
Cinematic Universe but jgl has denied
them all from Doctor Strange to Ant-Man
nevertheless according to deadline the
actor was in the running for the role
Peter Quill AKA starboard which he
allegedly turned down to play the
character of Johnny in Sin City a Dame
to kill them which probably wasn't a
great choice for Gordon Levitt but we're
pretty happy with Chris Pratt
Olivia Munn when Deadpool hit theaters
in early 2016 Ruby goers went wild so
the film's raunchy humor and bloody
shootouts X-Men apocalypse on the other
hand wasn't quite so successful limping
away from theaters with a Rotten Tomato
score of 48 but none of these numbers
really mattered to Olivia Munn before
signing up to play the role of psylocke
in X-Men man was first offered the role
of Vanessa Carlisle Deadpool's Scrappy
girlfriend munt turned the part down in
favor of playing the spandex clap button
saying that she wasn't interested in
playing the protagonist's eye candy
instead she wanted to be a character
with powerful abilities extreme fighting
skills and a costume that's pretty much
Underpants
Mel Gibbs it was a crew of the Marvel's
movies when Award winner Anthony Hopkins
agreed to join the MCU as Odin Orr's
father and king of Asgard while he seems
like an obvious pick for the role he
wasn't the only actor in the running for
the all father in an interview with the
guardian Mel Gibson explained that he
was asked to play Odin but as he
succinctly put it I didn't do it the
first glance the action star seems like
an odd pick to play the stately Norse
God but with a solid background in
Shakespearean theater Gibson probably
would have felt comfortable with Odin's
aristocratic dialogue of course with all
the controversy surrounding the actor it
was probably best to the MCU that Gibson
turned down the part
Jessica Chastain Iron Man 3 was the
second highest grossing domestic movie
of 2013 and its praise and Prophet is an
undeserved audiences enjoyed witty
dialogue a brilliant plot twist and one
of the greatest ending set pieces of
Marvel movie history the only thing it
really lacked was Jessica Chastain the
studio wanted Chastain to play the part
of Maya Hansen a scientist who may or
may not be on Tony Stark's side
unfortunately Chastain had to pass on
the role because she was just too busy
she said to her Facebook fans I know
many of you want me to be involved and
I'm sorry to disappoint you hopefully
there will be another Marvel film in my
future of course it isn't like
Chastain's decision hurt her career
after she turned down the role it went
to Rebecca Hall originally Maya Hansen
was supposed to be the ultimate villain
of the film but someone up the chain of
command ordered writer director Shane
black to make the bad guy a nude because
female action figures supposedly don't
sell that well leaving Hall in a much
less important role than anticipated
Joaquin Phoenix when Marvel Studios Was
preparing to introduce audiences to Dr
Stephen Strange there were a few names
at the top of their list they were
allegedly interested in the likes of
Jared Leto and Ryan Gosling but it seems
Joaquin Phoenix came even closer to
Landing the gig the oscar-nominated star
ultimately decided the path in his
sorcerer's Supreme because he didn't
feel he would do well in his Studio full
of green screens and the role went to
Benedict Cumberbatch however there was a
brief bit of time where it seemed
Cumberbatch wouldn't be able to wear the
cloak of levitation as he'd already
signed up to play Hamlet in a London
Stage production to accommodate
cumberbatch's schedule the studio ended
up pushing back Doctor Strange's release
date Emily Blunt Marvel realized Emily
Blunt's actions stopped attention long
before the rest of his as Kevin feige
and John Favreau prepared to shoot Iron
Man 2. they offered the English actress
one of the biggest roles in the Marvel
Cinematic Universe Natasha Romanov AKA
Black Widow unfortunately for blunt the
timing just didn't work out she was busy
with the Jack black comedy Gulliver's
Travels and had to pass on playing the
Russian super spy which was a pretty
huge mistake Marvel still really wanted
Glenn to join the MCU so when it came
time to film Captain America the First
Avenger execs asked if she'd be
interested in playing Steve Rogers
capable love interest Peggy Carter once
again the timing was off and the part
went to Haley Atwell in a 2012 interview
with vulture one admitted that she still
owe me to a superhero role as long as
she gets to play a hero saying usually
the female parts in a superhero film
feel thankless she's the pill girlfriend
while the guys are whizzing around
saving the world Matthew McConaughey if
you've seen Guardians of the Galaxy it's
easy to see why people are incredibly
psyched for its sci-fi Sequel and it
seems like any actor in Hollywood would
gladly sign up for a trip to Xander for
example both Sylvester Stallone and Kurt
Russell will appeal alongside Chris
Pratt but despite all the excitement not
every actor is willing to soar off into
space with Star-Lord in an interview
with Playboy Oscar winner Matthew
McConaughey said she was offered a role
in volume 2 but turned it down to appear
in an adaptation of Stephen King's The
Dark Tower saying I like Guardians of
the Galaxy but what I saw was it's
successful and now we've got room to
make a colorful part for another big
name actor I'd feel like an amendment
but konahay didn't say which party was
offered in volume 2 though I most agree
he would have played a villain still the
guardian sequel should be plenty of fun
even without McConaughey in the filmed
though it would be a lot cooler if you
signed up
[Music]
love him or hate him there's no denying
Quentin Tarantino is one of the most
influential directors of all time so it
goes without saying that many actors
would love to be in one of his movies
these however are the stars who passed
up that golden opportunity Michael
Madsen and Tarantino first met when the
actor auditioned for the role of Mr Pink
in Reservoir Dogs according to Madsen
after doing his best to land the gig
Tarantino responded you're not Mr Pink
you're Mr blonde and if you're not Mr
blonde then you're not in the movie
Madsen made the wise decision and
forever scarred moviegoers with a
straight razor and can of gasoline and
he evidently impressed Tarantino since
the auteur wanted Madsen to play Pulp
Fiction's dancing Hitman Vincent Vega
and you know what they call a quarter
pounder with cheese
and what do they call it they call it
Royale which
unfortunately for Madsen he'd already
signed up to play vigil Earp in Wyatt
Earp a western starring Kevin Costner as
the titular Lawman according to the
Daily Beast it took a long time for
Tarantino to forgive Madsen for turning
down Vincent Vega Madsen probably
regretted his choice as well since Pulp
Fiction is widely hailed as one of the
greatest movies of all time of course it
was probably for the best after all in
hindsight it's hard to imagine anyone
other than John Travolta playing the
smarmy Hitman plus if we'd seen Michael
Madsen dancing again we probably would
have suffered some pretty traumatizing
flashbacks Warren Beatty is one of the
most iconic members of the Tinseltown
Elite and as one of the biggest actors
of the 60s and 70s he's appeared in some
truly memorable films for example
there's Bonnie and Clyde Reds and McCabe
and Mrs Miller but for all the great
movies he's worked on Beatty has turned
down a shocking number of Classics as
you might have guessed Beatty also said
no to Quentin Tarantino so what role did
Tarantino offer Beatty well the director
wanted him to play the titular
antagonist and Kill Bill in fact he'd
written the part with Beatty in mind
only instead of creating the character
as a Kung Fu killer he'd written a
villain who was a bit more Suave and
sophisticated whom according to
Tarantino was quote much more of a James
Bond type of character tragically for
Tarantino Beatty wasn't interested in
shooting scenes in China preferring to
stay in the United States with his kids
however Beatty does take credit for the
casting of David Carradine claiming he
suggested Tarantino picked the martial
arts actor if so it was a genius
recommended station and Tarantino
rewrote the script so the character
would be a better fit
you're not a bad person
you're a terrific person
you're my favorite person
people often forget that Sylvester
Stallone is a great actor while the
razzies are happy to hurl Awards his way
Stallone has more than proved his acting
shops in movies like Rocky First Blood
Copland and Creed as he made missteps
along the way more than a few but he's
also the guy who reminded Roger Ebert of
a young Marlon Brando in other words the
man has genuine talent and a spotty
track record which is the perfect type
of actor to star in a Tarantino movie
but life is cruel and we've never gotten
the Stallone Tarantino pairing we
deserve of course we shouldn't blame the
director for this travesty in an
interview with the Canadian magazine
McLean's Stallone revealed he was
offered not one but two roles in
separate Tarantino films according to
slide the director first asked if he
wanted to play the part of Lewis The
Quiet yet Psychopathic Thug in Jackie
Brown Stallone turned him down for
undisclosed reasons and the part of Gara
ended up in Robert De Niro's more than
capable hands undaunted Tarantino later
off Stallone the Death Proof part of
stuntman Mike McKay a serial killer who
dispatches of young women with a
specialized stunt car when Stallone
learned about those gory details he told
Tarantino he wasn't interested explain
to McLean's I have two daughters and
this fellow his hobby is putting
teenagers in his car and smashing them
into a wall that's not going to work
instead the part went to Kurt Russell
who after coming off movies like Miracle
Sky High and dreamer was probably
Overjoyed to Rika little Mayhem this car
is 100 Death Proof
imagine if you will a world where
Leonardo DiCaprio played Colonel Hans
Landa you can't can you it's practically
impossible to see anyone other than
Christoph Waltz portraying the Bingo
loving monster but according to MTV
Tarantino originally considered giving
DiCaprio the part before choosing to go
with someone who could speak German
Tarantino also thought about giving the
role of Bridget Von hammersmark to
Nostalgia Kinski and he considered both
Simon Pegg and Tim Roth as possibilities
for the part of Lieutenant Archie Hickox
however for one reason or another those
actors all fell by the wayside and the
roles went to Diane Kruger and Michael
Fassbender respectively
but here's the weirdest casting tidbit
of all Once Upon a Time Tarantino wanted
Adam Sandler for the role of Sergeant
Dani donowitz at first glance the idea
seems ridiculous but despite movies like
Jack and Jill Sandler really is a
skilled actor who can do good work if he
puts his mind to it and if you've seen
punch drunk love you know he can
certainly smash a restroom helping
Sandler would trade his tire iron for a
baseball bat Tarantino made the
character a Bostonian because as he
explained to Howard Stern Sandler does a
great Boston accent but alas Sandler
dashed Tarantino's dreams when he signed
on to do funny people instead the part
went to Eli Roth who did a bang-up job
if Adam Sandler can't beat up Bob Barker
then he probably isn't ready for the
Third Reich just yet
I ain't you bad enough no
[Music]
now you've had enough
you've probably heard that Will Smith
opted to stay on the sidelines when the
wachowskis offered him the part of Neo
in The Matrix series but you might not
have known that when Tarantino Came
Calling he couldn't convince the actor
to say yes either Tarantino wanted Smith
to play the part of Django in a
spaghetti western Django Unchained
according to a 2015 Interview With The
Hollywood Reporter Smith quote wanted to
make that movie so badly but he turned
it down because in his opinion it had to
be a love story not a Vengeance story
violence begets violence I just couldn't
connect to violence being the answer
love had to be the answer that certainly
sounds nice and perhaps Tarantino's
penchant for Bloodshed really did affect
Smith's decision but if you go back to
2013 you'll see Smith gave a very
different excuse for why he passed on
Django Unchained
according to an interview with
Entertainment Weekly he turned down the
role because it wasn't big enough he
felt Kristoff waltz's Dr King Schultz
was actually the main character
especially since it's Schultz who shoots
the film's big bad guy this didn't sit
well with Smith who tried to convince
Tarantino to change things up as Smith
put it quote I was like no Quentin
please I need to kill the bad guy
sounds a little different than violence
begets violence eh
[Music]
Will Smith wasn't the only major star to
turn down Django Unchained it seems like
every actor in Hollywood was offered a
part only to pass at the last second for
example Joseph Gordon-Levitt was
originally going to play a small
supporting role but left to work on his
directorial debut Don John similarly
Rizza of the Wu-Tang Clan was meant to
play a small part but had to leave to
edit his martial arts movie The Man with
the Iron Fists according to Indy wire So
many actors were forced to jump ship
because filming on Django Unchained went
massively over schedule in fact the
movie took so long to make that
Tarantino was forced to scrap an entire
character originally the film was
supposed to feature a young man named
Scotty Harmony a gambler who takes
possession of Broom-Hilda jango's wife
only to lose her to the villainous
Calvin candy in a card game the role was
originally meant to be played by Jonah
Hill but just like Rizza and Gordon
Levitt he was forced to drop out due to
scheduling conflicts only to return in a
minor role for one of the funniest
scenes in Tarantino's whole filmography
fee anybody bring any extra bags no
nobody brought an extra bag I'm just
asking ultimately Tarantino decided to
go with Sasha Baron Cohen as Harmony
which obviously meant the character
needed a bit of a rewrite originally
Harmony was supposed to be quote
sexually inexperienced and naive and
Baron Cohen doesn't exactly fit that
bill
but scheduling conflicts struck yet
again when the actor had to leave to
promote his upcoming film The Dictator
forced with setback after setback
Tarantino cut Harmony out of the film
completely and unfortunately that wasn't
the only character who didn't make the
final draft
in the original screenplay for Django
Unchained Ace Woody worked directly
under Calvin candy as the guy who taught
slaves how to fight to the death if
Woody had made it to the Silver Screen
there's no doubt we would have witnessed
some brutal acts of violence as the
screenplay has him tortured Django but
just like Scotty Harmony the part of Ace
Woody wasn't meant to be all because
Tarantino couldn't keep an actor around
long enough to play the part at first
Woody was supposed to be played by Kevin
Costner while he's been in a handful of
westerns Dances with Wolves Silverado
open range it's not all that often
Costner plays a villain too bad he never
got the chance to go toe-to-toe with
Jamie Foxx because scheduling got in the
way again possibly due to projects like
Hatfields and McCoys as a result the
part of Woody was given to Kurt Russell
but the star evidently got sick of how
long it was taking for Tarantino to get
anything done allegedly Russell left the
project in frustration once again
Tarantino was forced to erase one of his
characters but since he had a lot of
good dialogue lying around he decided to
give those extra lines to Billy Crash
the villain played by Walton Goggins and
while kosner and Russell would have been
great as Ace Woody we really can't
complain the more Goggins the better
while Viggo Mortensen has committed his
fair share of on-screen Bloodshed be it
against Orcs and Lord of the Rings or
mobsters and Eastern Promises somehow
the actor and Tarantino have never
gotten together though it's not for lack
of trying in an interview with Grantland
Mortensen revealed he actually
auditioned for two parts in Reservoir
Dogs and while he doesn't remember which
roles he tried out for he did try to
play one as Hispanic Tarantino decided
to pass on the actor but a few years
later the situation was reversed this
time the director was interested in
having Mortensen play quote a ruthless
gang leader in the hateful eight as
there's only one gang leader in the film
it's safe to assume Tarantino wanted
Mortensen to play the ruthless Jodi
domergue unfortunately Mortensen had to
skip on the French lessons as he was
busy promoting two smaller films he'd
recently made hauha and far from Men
Mortenson told Grant land I knew as a
producer and an actor that I needed to
do that for those movies to have a
chance to be seen Tarantino wanted to
start shooting at the end of the year
and do rehearsal before that I just
couldn't do that schedule-wise the role
eventually went to Channing Tatum and
the actor pulled it off with psychotic
charm despair
if you
was a cat
what just happened here
when it comes one of your nine lives
when writing the screenplay for the
hateful eight Tarantino had an actor in
mind for every single character except
two he wasn't sure who would play Bob
though the role went to Demi and vichir
and he didn't know who was going to play
the female lead Daisy domergue while
pondering his predicament Tarantino
considered Jennifer Lawrence for the
part and he even met with the actress to
discuss the possibility of her squaring
off against Samuel L Jackson however as
Tarantino explained Lawrence was working
on Joy and promoting The Hunger Games
Mockingjay Part Two in other words she
was swamped and couldn't spare anytime
while he was probably disappointed at
first Tarantino eventually decided
Lawrence probably wasn't right for the
part he told Entertainment Weekly I'm
glad I didn't cast somebody that young I
think I absolutely positively made the
right choice as far as the ages of the
characters instead the director went
with an older actress 53 year old
Jennifer Jason Lee who earned an Oscar
nod for her Sinister performance as the
calculating outlaw
the Lord of the Rings trilogy has become
so ingrained in popular culture that
it's difficult to imagine how it might
have looked with a different cast but
several notable actors turned down big
roles here are some of the names who
could have resided in Middle Earth
according to reports Sean Connery was
offered the role of Gandalf before it
went to Ian McKellen Peter Jackson was
apparently so keen on Landing the former
Bond actor that he convinced new line to
offer Connery a 15 slice of the box
office takings plus a 30 million dollar
pay packet the Lord of the Rings trilogy
made just shy of three billion worldwide
so it was a pretty costly decision
especially when you consider the fact
that Connery went on to star in the
career ending the League of
Extraordinary Gentlemen instead so why
did the iconic Scot turn down the chance
to play tolkien's most famous wizard
ah I'll take swords for 400. in 2012 a
retired Connery admitted that he said no
to the Lord of the Rings because he just
couldn't get his head around the
sprawling Story the actor said I read
the book I read the script I saw the
movie I still don't understand it Ian
McKellen I believe is marvelous in it
when McClellan was asked about Jackson's
pursuit of Connery during an interview
with total film he joked that the films
would have been quote very different had
Connery chosen to take on the role
saying Gandalf would have come from
Scotland for a start you shall not pass
doesn't have quite the same ring to it
does it stay back if you value your life
Christopher Plummer grew up reading the
Lord of the Rings and has admitted to
being a huge fan of tolkien's world but
he still chose to turn down the
opportunity to play Gandalf when Peter
Jackson Came Calling years later the
actor revealed that he had an issue with
the level of commitment required for
Plummer spending three years in New
Zealand at his age just wasn't an option
he explained to Conan O'Brien I thought
there are other countries I'd also like
to visit before I quote he added did
that the quote absolutely marvelous Ian
McKellen brought a warmth to the wizard
that he himself may not have been able
to produce I might have been a little
cold and imperious plumber has still
done some memorable work since passing
on rings not that he had anything left
to prove after carving out his
illustrious career he was nominated for
a prime time Emmy for playing Cardinal
Bernard law in the Catholic Church abuse
drama our fathers in 2005 and in 2012 he
scooped up his first Academy Award
triumphing in the best supporting actor
category for beginners his win made him
the oldest actor to take home a
competitive Oscar Plummer almost beat
his own record in 2018 when he was
nominated for all the money in the world
a role he famously took over for a
scandal hit Kevin Spacey at the last
minute but he was beaten by Sam Rockwell
for three Billboards outside ebbing
Missouri Peter Jackson is said to have
attempted to convince Daniel Day-Lewis
to take on the role of Aragon on
numerous occasions supposedly the
three-time best actor winner repeatedly
spurned his advances according to the
One Ring which had the inside track on
all things the Lord of the Rings back
when the trilogy was still in
development in October 1999 A source
told the Tolkien fan site that producers
had made one final push to get Day Lewis
on board stating ddl has been offered
the Aragorn role again he has been
offered the Middle Earth to take the
role The Producers think he'll say no
again but they don't want to miss the
chance to try him
Jay Lewis addressed the long-running
Aragorn rumors over a decade later
confirming that he was indeed offered
the part speaking to MTV's Josh Horowitz
in 2009 the notoriously picky method
actor said that he rejected the role
because big franchise films just aren't
his bag he explained they can be
fantastically entertaining for the
people who love to see them but it's not
for me if I found myself working on a
film and during the course of that work
I was bored because I didn't really know
what the hell I was involved in I would
find that infinitely demoralizing and it
might well make me decide to pack my
bags Day Lewis retired from acting in
2017. the idea of Nicholas Cage playing
Aragorn might sound like nightmare fuel
but believe it or not this almost came
to pass cage was a headliner at the time
Fresh Off starring roles in Conair
Face-Off and snake eyes
no yes no come on this is not fair man
come on
taking the lead in a big budget epic
like the Lord of the Rings would have
been the next logical step for him but
he was forced to turn down Peter
Jackson's offer because he had quote
family obligations that he couldn't
ignore it wasn't the only huge role he
passed on either cage also said no to
the Matrix the actor said both are great
movies but they both shop for great
quantities of time I mean years
Australia was The Matrix and New Zealand
was The Lord of the Rings cage expanded
on his explanation during a 2015
interview with Newsweek where he said of
The Lord of the Rings there were
different things going on in my life at
the time that precluded me from being
able to travel and be away from home for
three years
he has absolutely no regrets however
saying I get to enjoy the movies as an
audience member because I don't watch my
own movies had his schedule been
different perhaps the state of his
career today would be different too For
Better or Worse cage was unable to take
the part and we're left wondering what
bizarre accent he might have given the
future king of Gondor by the time New
Zealand native Russell Crowe was
approached about the Aragorn vacancy the
Lord of the Rings budget was starting to
look a little stretched they didn't have
enough cash to give Crow a suitable
upfront fee so producers offered him a
percentage of the takings instead it
wasn't enough to tempt him though years
later Crow conceded that it would have
been a risk well worth taking in 2011
the actor delivered a lecture about his
career in the business to film students
at England's Durham University according
to the telegraph Crow talked about
turning down the Aragorn role joking
that he wouldn't have needed to do paid
appearances had he agreed to newline's
offer of 10 of The Lord of the Rings
prophets so why didn't he Crow didn't
reveal the reasoning behind his costly
decision until 2019 when Howard Stern
decided to probe him about it I didn't
think Peter Jackson actually wanted me
on the film
because I think he was forced into
talking to me because there was a moment
in time when any everybody wanted me and
everything Crow knew that something
wasn't right when he spoke to Jackson
over the phone about the part though he
said he had an instinct Jackson wanted
someone else for the part Viggo
Mortensen Kate Winslet started getting
linked with a possible appearance in The
Lord of the Rings as soon as new line
announced that Peter Jackson was going
to spearhead its ambitious three movie
Project the director gave the British
Starlet her big break when he cast her
in 1994's Heavenly Creatures a
psychological drama based on a famous
New Zealand case involving two teenage
killers by the time Jackson started
casting for the Lord of the Rings
Winslet was a huge star having been
nominated for Academy Awards in the best
supporting actress and best leading
actress categories for 1995's Sense and
Sensibility and 1997's Titanic
respectively
she had her pick of projects at the time
and the Lord of the Rings just wasn't
appealing enough
Winslet was reportedly offered the role
of Rohan shield made in eowin but she
had some commitment issues according to
an email allegedly written by former New
Line Cinema president of production
Michael DeLuca the supposed email which
was forwarded to the Lord of the Rings
fan site for one ring by an inside
source read Winslet's unavailable I'm
afraid I think she passed on the project
due to the length of time it takes some
people might view that as a gross error
of judgment on Winslet's part but her
career didn't suffer as a result she's
been nominated for another four Oscars
in the years since winning one
Uma Thurman certainly has a high fantasy
look about her it's easy to imagine the
actress as Galadriel but that's not the
part that Peter Jackson had in mind for
her the director wanted Thurman to play
aowin the same character that Kate
Winslet was approached about Thurman
also turned the part down though unlike
Winslet it wasn't just a Time issue she
and her then husband Ethan Hawke had
just welcomed their first daughter Maya
when the offer was made presenting the
new mother with a difficult choice in
the end Thurman decided to put Family
First and reject Jackson's overtures
though she later admitted that the
decision still haunts her she confirmed
to MTV in 2008. yeah I was asked it just
caught me at the wrong moment I wish I
had done it oh I truly wish I could have
been able to take that plunge and maybe
I should have but I just couldn't at the
time when she appeared on The Late Show
with Stephen Colbert almost a decade
later the Kill Bill star admitted that
rejecting the Lord of the Rings was
quote one of the worst decisions of her
entire career I just had my first child
and I just I don't know I was a little
housebound
at one stage husband and wife team Uma
Thurman and Ethan Hawke looked set to
appear in The Lord of the Rings together
with the latter confirming his planned
involvement at the Toronto Film Festival
Hawke not only revealed that he would be
playing boromia's younger brother
faramir a role that eventually went to
Australian actor David Wenham he also
let slip that tolkien's enigmatic
supporting character Tom Bombadil had
been cut from the screenplay the actor
went on to gush over the author's work
claiming he had been a fan of the
Tolkien series since childhood despite
his obvious excitement Hawk pulled out
of the pitcher perhaps leaving his wife
at home to care for their newborn
daughter after she had turned down a
part in the same movie wasn't an option
for the actor who takes Parenthood so
seriously that he was inspired to write
a book about it his now ex-wife has
admitted that she regrets rejecting the
Lord of the Rings but does Hawk feel the
same he didn't explicitly say that he
wished he had taken the faramir role but
when he sat down with Variety in 2018 he
revealed that he was still waiting for
his big Blockbuster moment saying before
I die I would really like to give a
meaningful performance inside a really
commercial film Lucy Lawless is best
known for starring in the much-loved
Xena Warrior Princess the New Zealander
seemed to be the perfect fit she had
plenty of fantasy experience and the
kind of flawless features that Galadriel
is known for in the novels but it wasn't
meant to be
sometimes people do things that they
regret Lawless was pregnant when Jackson
approached her about the role and the
director clearly failed to sell the Lord
of the Rings to her because she forgot
to turn up for the audition in a 2003
interview with hot celebs magazine
Lawless revealed that she also turned
down a chance to appear in Fox's
franchise opener X-Men at the time
despite knowing that she probably
wouldn't get another shot at the big
leagues she said you know what might
happen by the time I'm ready and want to
do a multi-year contract they won't want
me but what can I do I've turned down
great things it's not worth it if your
children are miserable her prediction
came true and although Lawless is still
working today having starred in the
Australian crime series my life is
murder in 2019 and voiced an alien queen
in two 2020 episodes of Star Wars
resistance her career could have been a
whole lot different if she had agreed to
portray tolkien's telepathic elf
sure it's nice to see actors starring in
roles they were almost destined to play
Robert Downey Jr is Tony Stark Sigourney
Weaver as Ellen Ripley Arnold
Schwarzenegger as the Terminator
Sylvester Stallone is Rocky but
sometimes an actor only has a shot and
an iconic role after someone else turns
it down although everything worked out
in the way it was supposed to in the end
we still can't help wondering what could
have been if these actors didn't say no
no
no no number one Thomas Jane as Don
Draper when we think of Mad Men We Think
Of The Dashing and duplicitous Jon Hamm
but ham told Mark Maron on the WTF
podcast back in 2011 that the role which
gave him his break almost went to
someone else and they went to Thomas
Jane uh
for it and they were told that Thomas
Jane does not do television whether or
not that's true Jane later did take a
regular television role starring on
HBO's hung for three seasons number two
Matthew Broderick and John Cusack as
Walter White after earning sitcom Fame
and Malcolm in the Middle Brian Cranston
made a huge career Elite when he was
cast as science teacher turned meth
Kingpin Walter White on Breaking Bad
while Show creator Vince Gilligan always
wanted Cranston The Hollywood Reporter
revealed that AMC wasn't interested
instead the network wanted Matthew
Broderick or John Cusack and take on the
lead role luckily for Cranston both
baby-faced actors passed and after exec
saw cranston's dramatic work in The
X-Files everyone was on board
or else number three Emily Blunt as
Black Widow Scarlett Johansson totally
and literally kills as the Marvel
Cinematic Universe version of Natasha
Romanov AKA The Black Widow but the role
was almost given to Emily Blunt who had
to back out she's fine with it though as
she explained the Screen Rant quote I
didn't do it at the time because it
wasn't the right time and it was
contracted to do something else but
Scarlett has done such a phenomenal job
she's it number four Annette Benning as
Catwoman for many Michelle Pfeiffer is
the only Catwoman having stolen the show
in Tim Burton's Batman Returns but as
Blaster points out the role was
originally intended for Annette Benning
who dropped out when she became pregnant
with her first child right before
shooting started Pfeiffer had been
gunning for the role from the moment
she'd read the script so she slipped
right in number 5. Will Smith as Neo
it's true Will Smith turned down the
iconic Sci-Fi Action Fleck The Matrix
everything's turned out just fine with
the Fresh Prince since then but he
explained his decision to wired in 2004
quote The Matrix is a difficult concept
to pitch in the pitch I just didn't see
it I watched Kiana's performance and
very rarely do I say this but I would
have messed it up I would have
absolutely messed up the Matrix instead
he saved that honor for the Wild Wild
West number six duggery Scott as
Wolverine originally Douglas Scott was
tapped to play Wolverine in the original
2000 film X-Men but after scheduling
conflicts with his role in Mission
Impossible 2 the gig went to Hugh
Jackman now one of the biggest stars in
the world no hard feelings though Scott
told the Daily Record quote I like you
he's a really lovely guy it wasn't as if
he stole it off me basically my movie
ran over and I had to pull out speaking
of Japan number 7 Hugh Jackman as James
Bond
with Duggar Scott we had someone passing
on Wolverine to take on the role of a
spy here we have Wolverine passing on
the role of the most iconic spy in the
world Entertainment Weekly reports that
Japan was considered for 007 back when
he was filming the second X-Men film
Jackman would have replaced Pierce
broston after Die Another Day but
Jackman didn't feel that it was the
right time still he remarked that it was
a very hard role to pass up comic Geeks
kept their Wolverine and the rest of the
world got Daniel Craig
number eight Tom Hanks as Jerry Maguire
writer and director Cameron Crowe
originally wrote Jerry Maguire with Tom
Hanks in mind unfortunately Hanks was a
little too old to play the young upbeat
sports agent that Tom Cruise made famous
Hanks declined the project after reading
an early draft of the script
speaking with Empire magazine in April
of 1997 Crow said Hank's past because he
didn't like the film's Romantic subplot
between Maguire and Renee Zellweger's
Dorothy Boyd number nine Pamela Anderson
as Dana Scully
before agents Mulder and Scully started
searching for aliens in The X-Files Fox
approached Baywatch star Pamela Anderson
to play the female FBI agent
entertainment Wheatley reported that
Jillian Anderson was the one who
revealed Fox's original choice for the
character quote she was someone who was
more familiar to them in terms of what
was on TV at the time they were looking
for someone bustier taller leggier than
me luckily Pam passed on the role and
Jillian's intelligent but skeptical
demeanor helped provide a great contrast
to David duchovny's Mulder leading the
show to 62 Emmy nominations and finally
number 10 Jean-Claude Van Damme as the
predator
believe it or not the muscles from
Brussels was originally supposed to play
the alien hunter in the 1987 classic
Predator Jean-Claude Van Damme arrived
on set thinking that he was going to use
his martial arts skills to fight a bunch
of soldiers it wasn't too long after
that when he found out he'd be wearing a
giant silly monster suit instead Van
Damme ran around in a red rubber suit
for a while but he hated the role after
all it was a hot suit and the movie was
filmed in a Mexican jungle and he
thought he'd be playing a human
eventually Van Damme volunteered to body
double for Arnold Schwarzenegger in a
few of the movie's explosive stunts
Instead The Predator suit was later
redesigned for Kevin Peter Hall whose
near seven foot tall height made him
Tower over his co-stars and was only
slightly more intimidating than Hall's
other most notable role
from an NBA star to the King of Pop
these famous figures turned down the
chance to work with the one and only
Adam Sandler the 1995 comedy Billy
Madison tells the story of dim-witted
Billy a privileged deadbeat poised to
inherit a chain of hotels from his
father Brian despite Billy having
graduated high school Brian reveals that
he had bribed Philly's school to let him
pass his classes now Billy must prove
himself capable of running the business
by going back to school and passing all
12 grades within six months if he fails
the business will belong to the hotel's
evil vice president Eric Gordon
you're going to give the company to Eric
he is a bad bad man initially Sandler
wanted Bob Odenkirk to be cast as the
villainous Eric as the two had gotten
along during their time on SNL but
Odenkirk far from the household name he
is today was vetoed by Studio Executives
after an extensive series of auditions
Sandler fell in love with the
performance of an up-and-coming actor
named Philip Seymour Hoffman but
Executives were reluctant to hire him
Sandler was able to convince them to
hire Hoffman but a new problem quickly
arose Hoffman ended up turning down the
roll in fly on the wall a podcast hosted
by David Spade and Dana Carvey Sandler
detailed how he called up Hoffman
personally to see what was going on he
recalled I go hey I saw your tape you're
so great buddy and they said you don't
want to do it so do you want to do it
and he goes oh I can't I just don't want
to the role ended up being delightfully
filled by The West Wing Star Bradley
Whitford fortunately Hoffman and Sandler
would eventually get the chance to work
together in Paul Thomas Anderson's
romantic dramedy Punch Drunk Love shut
up
will you shut up shut up shut shut shut
up following the highly successful Billy
Madison was Adam Sandler's classic 1996
Sports comedy Happy Gilmore the film
Chronicles the Journey of the titular
failed ice hockey player Happy who soon
discovers his talents transfer better to
the world of professional golf his more
rambunctious style rankles his uptight
competitor Shooter McGavin played by
Christopher McDonald who resorts to
nefarious means to get Gilmore off the
course McDonald's portrayal of shooter
is truly iconic but it almost didn't
happen in an interview with Alex Withrow
for end so it begins McDonald confirmed
that he had turned down the role twice
explaining I was tired I wanted to see
more of my family fortunately McDonald
changed his mind after winning a
particularly competitive game of golf he
continued that high was something else
so with my golf shoes still on I went in
the locker room called my agent and said
is that golf movie still available
because I just won this tournament and
I'm feeling a little bit well
shooter-ish I've worked hard my whole
life paid my dues and now it's Shooter's
turn and Shooter's not about to let his
Reign at the top be spoiled by some
freak Sideshow clown McDonald was cast
and movie Magic was made McDonald
enjoyed the freedom he was given to
improvise making sure his character
didn't just play all of the cliched bad
guy tropes though he initially declined
the role he now looks back on the film
as a blessing saying we really had fun
with that one and the fact that that
movie is still on people's minds is
great after Christopher McDonald
initially turned down the role of
Shooter McGavin in Happy Gilmore Studio
Executives began looking for a possible
replacement deciding to take a big swing
the studio reached out to Kevin Costner
legendary star of sports films like
Field of Dreams American flyers and Bull
Durham casting Costner as a golf player
sounds like a perfect fit and Costner
himself agreed but he still didn't agree
to the role of shooter instead he was
busy making his own golf movie 10 cup 10
cup earned Costner a Golden Globe
nomination for his role as Roy McAvoy so
it was probably worth it for him to
swing away from Happy Gilmore either
more Sports films followed for Costner
including Sam Ramey's For the Love of
the Game the football movie Draft Day
and Disney's McFarland USA but for a
brief Shining Moment the world was
nearly graced with Kevin Costner as one
of the funniest Sports film villains
ever after finding success with Happy
Gilmore Adam Sandler again returned to
Sports for the 1998 football comedy The
Waterboy Sandler stars as the titular
Waterboy Bobby Boucher who lives with
his overbearing mother played by Kathy
Bates when Bobby winds up playing
football instead of just handing out
drinks he begins to make his way out
from under his mother's thumb and into
the real world
Mama something bad happened today
somebody hurt you my boy who hurt you
you tell mama who hurt you the academy
award-winning Bates almost didn't play
the iconic role of Mama Boucher as her
agent didn't like the script Bates told
SB Nation they made an offer so legally
she had to send me the script and I read
the first 12 pages and it was about
football and it was kind of silly so I
tossed it in the trash next to my bed
fortunately Bates niece saw the script
and recognized Adam Sandler's name she
convinced Bates to give the script
another chance a decision that Bates now
knows was the right one to make she
reminisced there's many experiences I've
had that have been more difficult or
unpleasant or didn't turn out the way I
had wanted them to turn out this was one
of the happy experiences that I've had
in 2010 grown-ups became Sandler's
highest grossing film to date raking in
over 270 million dollars worldwide the
movie did so well that Sandler
generously gifted brand new Maseratis to
his co-stars Chris Rock Kevin James and
David Spade as well as a Tesla Roadster
to Rob Schneider after the Smashing
success of the first film a sequel
followed in 2013 with one major
difference Rob Schneider was absent
replaced by comedian Nick Swardson as
Schneider's character's brother when
questioned about his absence in a radio
interview Schneider initially made it
sound like there was bad blood between
him and Sandler because of pay disputes
he said they're doing grown-ups too
without me mistake they should have paid
me a lot of money however Schneider also
added while truthfully I wasn't sure if
I'd have my TV series so it was an
availability thing but at the end of the
day they should have said what money
does Rob need If there really was a
falling out behind the scenes the two
seemed to have made up Schneider has
gone on to appear in more recent Sandler
films including the ridiculous 6 Sandy
Wexler and Huey Halloween the 2015
action comedy pixels sees Adam Sandler
as Sam Brenner a former arcade Champion
recruited by the government to stop
aliens that are taking the form of
classic arcade games like Pac-Man
centipede and Donkey Kong in addition to
the gaming icons the aliens take on the
appearances of famous 80s faces like
Ronald Reagan and Max Headroom to
deliver their messages to mankind
according to a report from Showbiz 411
the infamous 2014 Sony email leak
revealed that the studio reached out to
the estate of Michael Jackson for a
potential cameo in pixels while the
estate didn't exactly turn them down
outright they did request a fee that
surpassed their budget by quite a large
amount although Sandler really wanted
the King of Pop to appear in the Sci-Fi
Adventure the Michael Jackson alien did
not moonwalk its way into the Final Cut
Adam Sandler's first of many Netflix
films was the Western parody the
ridiculous 6. the film star Sandler as a
man raised by Native Americans who
learns he has a handful of eccentric
half-brothers played by Terry Crews
Jorge Garcia Taylor Lautner Rob
Schneider and Luke Wilson the brothers
team up to rescue their Newfound
recently kidnapped father by stealing
enough money to pay his Ransom any of
you handsome Brothers ready to go steal
a big hunk of gold
I'm ready I'm hungry I'm drunk I'm low
feet despite its eclectic cast critics
and audiences alike were less than
pleased with the movie many criticized
the film as racially insensitive with
loads of unfunny jokes that relied on
terrible stereotypes but it wasn't just
the audience saying so this criticism
also came from some of the movie's own
cast members as reported by Indian
country today many of the Native
American extras were upset at the
lowbrow jokes and inaccurate costumes
this led to about a dozen actors and
crew members including actor Lauren
Anthony and the Native American Cultural
advisor to leave the set in protest
Netflix responded to the controversy by
telling Venture the movie has ridiculous
in the title for a reason because it is
ridiculous it is a broad satire of
western movies and the stereotypes they
popularized featuring a diverse cast
that is not only part of but in on the
joke perhaps the film's low approval
rating proves that Sandlers should have
listened to what his co-workers had to
say the 2022 Netflix Sports drama hustle
Stars Adam Sandler as down on his luck
NBA Scout Stanley Sugarman when he sent
to Spain to recruit a rising star
Sugarman stumbles across an even better
player named Beau Cruz played by juancho
Hernan Gomez unable to convince his boss
of Cruz's Talent Sugarman quits and
focuses on preparing Crews for the NBA
draft Hernan Gomez is an NBA star who's
previously played for a number of teams
currently for the Toronto Raptors hustle
was his acting debut but he was
initially reluctant to take the role in
an interview with pop culture Hernan
Gomez stated I told him no I mean I
didn't want to do it I mean I don't want
to waste time in something like this
it's not my dream eventually Hernan
Gomez was convinced by his sister to
take the role which he later described
as a great experience saying I was
really surprised how hard they work for
making a movie I just enjoy the journey
so much I mean I embrace it and I enjoy
it Hernan Gomez had a blast working with
Sandler feeling an instant connection
with the comedy Legend on set he
continued we enjoy it so much every
single day we spent two months together
we didn't have any bad days I feel like
that that's the reason Beau and Stanley
have that good chemistry because in real
life we got a great feeling while Adam
Sandler has acted in several dramatic
films none have quite the same impact as
his portrayal of the gambling addicted
jewelry salesman Howard Ratner in 2019's
uncut gems critics heaped Praise on his
performance and many believed the film
would earn Sandler his first Academy
Award nomination while the Oscar evaded
the Sandman he still managed to NAB best
actor wins from the Independent Spirit
Awards and the national board of review
this is my way this is how I win
alright of course he almost didn't take
the role at all filmmakers Josh and
Benny safdi initially reached out to
Sandler's Management in 2015 but were
told he was unavailable the brothers
made attempts with other actors
including Borat comedian Sacha Baron
Cohen and 21 Jump Street star Jonah Hill
after struggling to de-age the character
Hill eventually left to work on other
projects with more projects now under
their belt including the critically
acclaimed Robert pattinson-led Thriller
good time the safd brothers decided to
reach out to Sandler One Last Time
luckily this time he agreed to the role
ushering in a whole new era of critical
respect and acclaim for the famously
goofy actor the animated Hotel
Transylvania franchise has made over a
billion dollars worldwide Adam Sandler
lent his voice to the first three movies
as none other than Count Dracula who
owns the titular hotel for Monsters and
struggles to be a good father to his
daughter Mavis the films also feature a
number of Sandler's frequent live-action
collaborators including Andy Samberg
Kevin James Steve Buscemi and David
Spade when the fourth film Hotel
Transylvania transform Mania premiered
in 2022 on Amazon Prime most of the
actors reprise their monstrous roles
with two major exceptions first off
Frankenstein was no longer played by
Kevin James but instead by voice actor
Brad Abril more surprisingly though the
lead role of Dracula was now occupied by
Adam Sandler impressionist Brian Hull
director Derek dryman spoke of the
casting change telling Screen Rant the
fact that he turns into a human was a
good opportunity to do things a little
differently he could be a little
different than he was in the movies and
it would be natural so it kind of was
the perfect movie to have a person come
in and fill those shoes though there is
no official reason behind Sandler's lack
of involvement on the project some have
theorized that it had to do with this
Netflix contract and another animated
film he was developing with the
competing streaming service
Disney is one of the biggest film
studios on the planet and it's no secret
that a role in one of their
family-friendly Blockbusters can make an
actor's career however not everyone's
eager to work with the mouse house and
there are a number of stars who have
actually refused major roles in big
Disney movies and shows
Anne Hathaway although she did end up in
the movie Anne Hathaway actually had the
opportunity to take the lead role in Tim
Burton's Alice in Wonderland the actress
turned it down because she felt she had
already played a very similar princess
in a dress type role in The Princess
Diaries however Hathaway told the studio
should be willing to play the White
Queen instead and that's what she did it
ended up being a good decision as
Hathaway took home some awards for her
turn as the White Queen and it opened up
the door for newcomer Mia bashikovska to
take on the role of Alice Warren Beatty
Gilbert Gottfried ziago provided the
comic relief in Disney's Aladdin always
chiming in with a squawk or a screech to
lighten the mood during some of the
film's more intense moments oh Jafar
you're too kind I'm embarrassed however
according to the actor he almost didn't
get the chance to play the iconic role
Gottfried revealed in his Memoir that in
order to lands the part he had to be
told Joe Pesci and Danny DeVito
apparently the role was actually offered
to the star of the 2017 Oscar's best
picture mixer Warren Beatty Beatty
reportedly turned down the role because
playing a parrot in the desert felt too
similar to his role from Ishtar just
imagine how different the film would
have been without Gottfried's iconic
squawk I'm witch Aiden
Crystal
Toy Story is one of the most iconic
films of all time with a hundred percent
critical rating on Rotten Tomatoes while
Tim Allen's work as Buzz Lightyear as
classic it turns out that the character
was nearly brought to life by a
different actor Billy Crystal who would
become famous with Disney Pixar fans for
voicing Mike Wazowski in Monsters Inc
was offered the part in the early
planning stages of the film apparently
Pixar was so eager to get him to sign on
that's the studio actually animated an
early version of Buzz Lightyear with
some dialogue from When Harry Met Sally
the result is interesting happy everyone
is in love and that's wonderful but you
gotta know that someday believe it or
not you'll go 15 rounds over who's going
to get this coffee table as we all know
now Crystal turned it down and Tim Allen
got the part while Crystal has had a
great career he told ABC News in 2001
that passing on birds is actually
something he regrets interestingly the
Pixar movie Crystal did appear in almost
had a totally different co-star too
Bill Murray in 2001 Monsters Inc became
an instant classic for Disney and Pixar
fans the film won an Oscar and earned
further accolades for each of its two
main leads Billy Crystal and John
Goodman but Goodman who famously voiced
Sully almost didn't get the part
director Pete's doctor's Top Choice for
the part was actually legendary comedian
Bill Murray the actor screen tested for
the part and impressed doctor but when
he called to offer him the parts he
couldn't get Murray to pick up the phone
the director of another Murray movie
Saint Vincent explained just how
difficult it is to track the guy down
just to offer him work the job of Bill
Murray is really finding Bill Murray
which everyone knows once you find Bill
Murray and the job kind of goes downhill
Murray is notoriously hard to reach so
it's still unclear if this was his way
of saying he wasn't interested or it was
just a miscommunication either way you
won't hear any complaints about it from
John Goodman
Leonardo DiCaprio
Hocus Pocus may not have been the
biggest Disney film of all time but the
movie has a huge cult following and is
still the subject of many a Halloween
movie marathon the filmmakers were
especially picky about searching for
their star and they eventually narrowed
it down to the then up and comer
Leonardo DiCaprio to play Max despite
being offered some serious coin the
Caprio turned down the path because he
wanted to wait and see if it land the
role in What's Eating Gilbert Grape
though it was likely terrifying at the
time DiCaprio has said that this was the
best and the toughest decision he has
ever made it definitely worked out for
him as Leo earned his first Academy
Award nomination for What's Eating
Gilbert Grape and has been an a-lister
ever since Omri cats who eventually took
the role of Max and Hocus Pocus stopped
acting in 2002.
Lily Tomlin while it's hard to imagine
anything different in the Pixar classic
The Incredibles one of the film's
signature characters was almost voiced
by someone else Edina mode the superhero
stylist who really really hates capes
was voiced by director Brad Bird in the
final product knock it
however that's not what he had intended
apparently when bird recorded the voice
for Edna he was just filling in for
actress Lily Tomlin who was set to play
the part however when she heard Bird's
take on the character she decided that
it wasn't something she could improve on
you know you've made it in Show Business
when you can pass on a Disney movie
Paycheck and not bath and I Michael
Douglas in 2013 Frozen became a
commercial and critical success bringing
in over 1.3 billion dollars and winning
two Academy Awards the voice acting in
the movie was great but the casting
might have turned out differently
Michael Douglas told James Corden that
he turned down a part in the film but
couldn't remember exactly which role
no you want to play Elsa I don't
remember although we don't know for sure
our best guess is that Douglas was
offered either the Duke of wesselton
Hans or Kristoff although it would be
funny it's probably doubtful that
Douglas was ever in line to voice Olaf
Selena Gomez it's no secret that for
many years Selena Gomez was one of the
queens of the Disney Channel network
what's surprising though is that Gomez
actually ended up turning down the lead
role of Michi in Camp Rock because she
wanted to do more conventional and
serious acting before ultimately
transitioning into a more music-focused
career Gomez also reportedly turned down
an undisclosed part in High School
Musical 3 senior Year for similar
reasons these days Selena is one of the
most successful pop stars around but we
have to wonder just how much her serious
acting role in Spring Breakers really
helped her cause
Jack Nicholson Hercules is an animated
Disney classic and that's in large part
thanks to James Wood's smooth talking
Hades ladies
my fate is in your lovely hands however
the part was apparently written with
Jack Nicholson specifically in mind and
the studio tried their best to land him
for the role Well Jack likes the
creative side of the deal he and Disney
were unable to agree on the business end
of things so he ended up walking away
from the roll after testing actors like
Robert Evans and John Lithgow the
filmmakers landed on woods and the rest
is history could it be his great
Hercules performance that prompted Seth
McFarlane's strange obsession with James
Woods
James Woods has you and I have changed
words too
it may seem like everyone wants to be a
superhero these days but a few stars
have still tried to steer clear of the
world of comic book movies here are a
few of the actors who said no when DC
Came Calling
Leonardo DiCaprio has spent the vast
majority of his life in Hollywood but
before he achieved Global Fame in James
Cameron's 1997 epic Titanic Warner
Brothers approached him to starring Joel
Schumacher's Batman Forever seeing how
things turned out it's probably fair to
say that turning them down was the right
choice the studio wanted DiCaprio for
the part of Dick Grayson also known as
Robin but DiCaprio just wasn't feeling
it contrary to rumors DiCaprio has said
he never screen tested for the role
though he did talk to Schumacher he told
shortlist I had a meeting with Joel
Schumacher it was just one meeting and
no I didn't end up doing it despite
meeting with the director DiCaprio said
he never even wanted the role he
explained as I recall I took the meeting
but didn't want to play the role Joel
Schumacher is a very talented director
but I don't think I was ready for
anything like that the role ended up
going to Chris O'Donnell but
interestingly Robin wasn't the only
superhero role Hollywood offered to
Cabrio Sony Pictures approached him to
play Spider-Man for director Sam Raimi
but as as with Robin he said he just
wasn't ready to put on a suit at this
juncture in his oscar-winning career it
seems unlikely he's in any rush to
change his mind
Warner Brothers have been trying to get
a Green Lantern film off the ground for
well over a decade before Martin
Campbell directed the character's first
live-action outing in 2011. the studio
approached Kevin Smith in 1997 to write
a script for the film but he turned down
the offer feeling he wasn't the right
fit for the job then renowned director
Quentin Tarantino received an offer to
home the project but he also turned it
down feeling it outgrown his adoration
for comic books when the studio finally
settled on a director and screenwriter
they began their search for Hal Jordan
while Ryan Reynolds ultimately got the
part he wasn't always a top Contender
Warner Brothers approached Bradley
Cooper Chris Pine Justin Timberlake and
Sam Worthington who all either turned
the roll down or were rejected by the
studio another one-time Contender was
madman star Jon Hamm he recalled to GQ
they came after me pretty hard for Green
Lantern but I was like meh that's not
what I want to do Never Say Never but
these aren't the kind of movies I'd like
to go and see they don't make the kind
of movies I'd like to see anymore
nostalgia
it's delicate
but potent
Pierce Brosnan has had a hugely prolific
career but his tenure as the Slick MI6
spy James Bond will undoubtedly remain
its highlight at one point however
Brosnan had the opportunity to star in a
comic book movie that probably would
have not only dashed his chances to be
Bond but also changed the landscape of
the superhero genre altogether just
imagine for a second that Brosnan not
Michael Keaton played Batman in Tim
Burton's 1989 film sounds crazy but
there was a chance of it happening in a
Reddit AMA Brosnan admitted to meeting
Burton for the role he wrote yes I did I
went and met with Tim Burton for the
role of Batman but I just couldn't
really take it seriously any man who
wears his underpants outside his pants
just cannot be taken seriously that was
my foolish take on it it was a joke I
thought but how wrong was I Brosnan
stressed the fact that he doesn't hate
Batman he just couldn't see himself
playing the character in a movie he
wrote don't get me wrong because I love
Batman and I grew up on Batman as a kid
in Ireland we used to get our raincoats
and tie them around our neck and swing
through the bicycle shed however it
appears that Brosnan's hesitation with
Batman led him to James Bond and thus
gave him the defining role of his career
so it's not all bad
there aren't many actors more highly
regarded than Anthony Hopkins known to
many as Hannibal Lecter from The Silence
of the Lambs in its sequels Hopkins was
also up for a few early roles in the
world of comic book movies but declined
to take them before Michael Caine
boarded Christopher Nolan's Batman
Begins as Bruce Wayne's Butler Alfred
pennyworth Nolan reportedly offered
Hopkins the role he turned it down
however for reasons unknown
interestingly despite reportedly being
turned down for the role of Mr Freeze
and Joel Schumacher's Batman and Robin
Hopkins maintained his interest in DC
movies not long after turning down the
role of Alfred pennyworth in Batman
Begins he finally joined the DC
universe's jorel and JJ Abrams and Brett
ratner's Superman flyby things didn't
work out though and the project mutated
into Brian singer's Superman Returns he
told MTV News I was going to do the
movie with Brett and I don't know what
happened there was some political
movement I think Brett was out of line
with something and they said thank you
very much I never heard from Brett since
then but I was all set do it Hopkins
finally found his comic book home in
2011 when he took the role of Odin in
Thor a role he has returned to many
times since
Jude Law may be an excellent actor but
he's not really a huge movie star after
the disastrous critical and box office
performance of Sky Captain in the World
of Tomorrow law was probably nervous
about headlining another action
franchise especially when the character
in question was the greatest superhero
of them all on The Late Show with
Stephen Colbert law revealed that
director Brian Singer offered him the
role of the Man of Steel for 2006's
Superman Returns I have this picture
about of me in that costume you know on
posters all around the world and I was
like no way law turned down the role
which went to the relatively unknown
Brandon Ralph after Superman Returns
lukewarm reception the series was
rebooted with Law's fellow Brits Henry
Cavill taking the lead I'm an Englishman
and I've felt like you know I don't know
I just didn't seem to fit and and I was
always worried about the unit of the
outfit and I I just didn't fancy it La
presumably had no such qualms about the
Wardrobe attached to the character of
yon Rog the cree Warrior he played in
2019's MCU Blockbuster Captain Marvel
movie stars don't come much bigger than
Will Smith and this was especially true
in the mid-2000s so it seemed natural
that he'd end up taking apart in a
superhero movie and according to Smith
himself he wasn't just offered any
superhero role but the mightiest of them
all Superman apparently Brian Singer
asked Smith to play the Big Blue Boy
Scout and Superman Returns but Smith
didn't even need to see the suit he
rejected the part because he didn't want
to repeat what was then his biggest
career mistake Smith told MTV there is
no way I'm playing Superman because I
had already done Jim West in Wild Wild
West and you can't be messing up white
people's heroes in Hollywood you mess up
white people's heroes in Hollywood
you'll never work in this town again
Smith would go on to play his own
superhero in Hancock and would later
join the DC expanded universe as dead
shots
imagine living in an alternate universe
where Heath Ledger played Batman and
Christian Bale played The Joker well
it's not really that far-fetched in 2005
Ledger was Hollywood's Gravely voiced
king of cool while Bale was most known
for playing the maniacal murdering
psychopath Patrick Bateman an American
Psycho and according to the Dark Knight
trilogies director Christopher Nolan it
was almost Ledger not Bale who donned
the cape and Cal in an interview with
the Daily Star Nolan revealed that he
offered the part of Batman to Ledger but
was turned down Nolan said he was quite
gracious about it but he said I would
never take apart in a superhero film
thankfully Ledger eventually changed his
mind presumably after he saw Batman
Begins and realized Nolan was going for
a grittier more realistic take on the
character fortunately there were no hard
feelings on Nolan's end as he clearly
was a great admirer of Ledger's work The
Dark Knight would go on to be one of the
highest grossing movies of the decade
being the first film to earn over 500
million dollars domestically since
Titanic largely due to Ledger's
performance as the clown Prince of Crime
Ledger tragically died before the film's
release but his work won him his first
and only Oscar
it seems like everybody was considered
for the part of Wonder Woman at some
time or another though it's doubtful
many of the actresses considered were
ever formally approached for the role
one actress who was approached and
turned it down was Kate Beckinsale with
her lead role as vampire death dealer
Celine in the successful Underworld
franchise Beckinsale would have been a
perfect fit for the Amazonian warrior in
the mid-2000s alas the most recent
female superheroes on film during that
time were Halle Berry and Catwoman
Jennifer Garner and Elektra and Charlize
Theron in Eon flux not the best track
record and it sounds like this proposed
Wonder Woman vehicle wasn't going to be
much better speaking in reference to
2017's Wonder Woman Beckinsale later
told Yahoo movies the incarnations that
I was seeing were they weren't this one
but even if the script had been better
it sounds like Beckinsale would have
been hung up by the same thing which is
always worried actors playing
superheroes Beckinsale explained I don't
know if I was desperate to be in a
leotard now I'd already done the rubber
trousers you have to take in that you
have a child at some point and how much
could you possibly embarrass them
Charlize Theron wasn't up for the part
of Wonder Woman in the 2017 film but she
did turn down a major role as Wonder
Woman's mother hippolyta in an interview
with Andy Cohen on Watch What Happens
Live Theron explained she ended up in
talks for a part in the movie while it
was still in development but it wasn't
the one she expected and I was like just
I'm not I'm not familiar with it I don't
really know what it like I mean what
does Wonder Woman do and my this person
said no it's for Wonder Woman's mom
Theron of course is only 10 years older
than Wonder Woman star Gal Gadot despite
Wonder Woman being directed by Patty
Jenkins who directed Charlize Theron's
oscar-winning turn in 2003's Monster
Theron declined the part which went to
Connie Nielsen who was about 19 years
older than gduts director Zack Snyder
apparently felt slighted when Kristen
Stewart rejected the role of Lois Lane
in 2013's Man of Steel according to
sources close to the director he and his
wife producing partner Deborah met with
Stewart about playing the iconic
reporter while Snyder was interested in
Stuart however he apparently never
formally offered her the part but Stuart
made clear that she was not interested
evidently surprising Snyder Stewart
herself had been caught off guard by the
Blockbuster success of the Twilight
films and the spotlight it put on her
personal life especially her
relationship with co-star Robert
Pattinson Stewart was still working on
the Twilight series at the time and
wanted to focus on smaller more
independent films which Man of Steel
most definitely was not Snyder wasn't
upset for long however and soon hired
a-lister Amy Adams for the role but
Adams may have wished she'd turned down
the part 2. Stewart's focus on smaller
films gave her career A Renewed Vigor
while Snyder's DC films started with
poor feedback and continued on a
downward slide maybe Stewart on a Warner
X before he puts on that cow as the new
Batman
due to a combination of Savvy marketing
a powerful International draw and not
taking itself too seriously The Fast and
Furious franchise has become a veritable
money printing machine but not everyone
wants to be a part of it here are some
actors who turned down roles in the fast
Saga
Denzel Washington would have been a
massive get for the Fast and Furious
franchise the series has boasted its
fair share of Big Time actors but Denzel
is on another level not only has he been
incredibly successful at the box office
but he's also taken home two Oscars for
his roles in glory and Training Day hey
I know you got Secrets everybody got
secrets
didn't know you like to get wet though
deadline writes that Universal
approached Denzel to appear at the end
of the sixth film which would seg into
him playing the role of the main villain
in Furious 7. he apparently was not
interested however and turned down the
opportunity ultimately the role went to
Jason Statham Statham is obviously a big
star in his own right but not quite on
the same level as the two-time Oscar
winner
you may be unfamiliar with the name
Deepika Padukone unless you're a big fan
of Bollywood however the model actress
is hugely popular in Indian Cinema and
that makes her star in the largest film
producing industry in the world the Fast
and Furious franchise owes much of its
success to the international market so
it makes sense that they'd want to
recruit worldwide Stars into the fold
they tried to do just that with Padukone
and Furious 7 but she had to turn down
the offer at the time Padukone had never
appeared in an American Film as she told
India today she had already committed to
a domestic film and didn't feel right
backing out but she also said she would
love to do a Hollywood film in the
future she got her wish just a few years
later and in a role alongside Vin Diesel
as well paducon appeared in XXX return
of Xander cage in 2017 and has
reportedly been cast in xxx4
when the Fast and Furious franchise
began in 2001 Ja Rule was one of the
biggest rappers in the world he was in
the process of making the transition to
acting and appeared in a very small role
in The Fast and the Furious as a
character named Edwin who went up
against Paul Walker and Vin Diesel's
characters in a street race he did not
win
oh my God
interestingly Ja Rule could have gone on
to be one of the faces of the franchise
if he'd been interested in an interview
with Grantland John Singleton the
director of Too Fast Too Furious
recalled jaw got too big for himself he
turned it down he turned down a half a
million dollars to be in the sequel
Singleton said he repeatedly tried to
get jaw rule to the table but eventually
decided to swap his character out for
one played by a different rapper
Ludacris who has since appeared in more
than half of the Fast and Furious films
apparently Ludacris wasn't the first
potential replacement for Ja Rule
originally rapper Redman was eyed to
take on the role at the time Reggie
Redman Noble had found success as both a
solo rapper and part of the Wu-Tang Clan
and he had started to move into the
world of acting once Ja Rule dropped out
of Too Fast Too Furious red man was
apparently geared up to replace him he
apparently had to drop out due to
scheduling conflicts the TV series
method in red came out around the same
time as did a few other projects instead
the role went to Ludacris just like Ja
Rule Redman's acting career has been
fairly stagnant since this role passed
him by it would have been interesting to
see how the franchise might have evolved
if either one of them had been cast
instead of ludicrous
even though the Fast and Furious
franchise has become a blockbuster
series over the years it took a few
films for it to find its footing and
figure out what it wanted to be most of
the main players have stuck with it over
the Long Haul but the core group didn't
come together overnight in fact in 2017
a producer revealed that Timothy
Oliphant was initially targeted to star
in the first film apparently when the
Fast and the Furious was originally
pitched to Universal the studio agreed
to produce the film as long as elephant
was cast as the lead role of Dom Toretto
Oliphant turned the world down which
brought the filmmakers to their backup
Vin Diesel diesel took the reins of the
franchise and has appeared in almost
every film since
The Fast and Furious franchise sure
loves its European baddies in recent
films we've seen Luke Evans Jason
Statham and Idris Elba all show up as
Central antagonists an impressive roster
that also almost included David Tennant
yes we reportedly almost saw the
one-time Doctor Who tangling with Vin
Diesel and Dwayne Johnson so what went
wrong well I don't know I can't worry
about everything according to Latino
Review tenant was in talks with director
Justin Lin about taking on a major role
in Fast and Furious 6. we don't know
which part he was being considered for
but it seems likely that it would have
been one of the Shaw Brothers roles that
eventually went to Evans and Statham
whatever ultimately went down during
negotiations tenant wound up moving on
to other projects tenant has proven he
can do over-the-top felony very well his
performance in Jessica Jones as the
Despicable kilgrave gave audiences one
of the best Marvel villains to date we
certainly wouldn't mind seeing him get
behind the wheel in the Fast and Furious
franchise
another rapper who was targeted for the
franchise but had to turn it down Eminem
was actually approached twice to be a
part of The Fast and Furious films both
times prior commitments kept him from
coming on board and both roles he turned
down would go on to be major parts in
the films Eminem was actually offered a
very big role in the first film he was
approached to take on the role of Brian
O'Connor which eventually went to Paul
Walker when Eminem was approached to
take the role he was currently in
development of his own film Eight Mile
and had to remain available for it just
think Eminem could have been one of the
faces of the franchise according to fuse
Eminem was later approached to do a song
for the soundtrack of furious 7. he
again turned it down due to a different
film he was already heavily involved
with the movie Southpaw and he did not
want to have multiple songs competing
with one another
Eliza deshku was extremely in demand
when the Fast and the Furious was in
development apparently the role of Mia
Toretto was not only offered to Dushku
but was reportedly written specifically
with her in mind dashku turned the world
down for unknown reasons but she was
extremely busy at the time with both
television and film projects so it isn't
hard to imagine why many different stars
were reportedly attached after Dushku
passed Jessica Biel Kirsten Dunst Sarah
Michelle Geller Bijou Phillips and
Natalie Portman are all rumored to have
auditioned for the role before it went
to Jordana Brewster Vin Diesel returned
to the franchise fold later but he did
refuse an opera to appear in Too Fast
Too Furious and the reason is
fascinating diesel was offered 25
million dollars to star in Too Fast Too
Furious but didn't like the script or
the direction the series was headed he
viewed the first film as a classic and
said I was an idealist and to me the
script wasn't continuing the story they
were capitalizing on the brand and
milking the success of it as long as
they could of course since diesel
full-time return to the franchise with
the fourth installment The Fast and
Furious movies have morphed from a story
about cops out to infiltrate a street
racing gang into a wildly over-the-top
Saga fueled by Globe trotting action
Espionage and an increasingly casual
relationship with the loss of nature
the ground's coming fast continuing the
story will only take you so far
this one is a bit of a cheat because as
far as we can tell Guardians of the
Galaxy Star Dave Batista has never
actually been offered a role in the
franchise that said his refusal of a fan
pitch was enough of an adamant refusal
that we had to include it once the news
broke that John Cena would be appearing
in F9 a fan tagged Batista on Twitter
with this pitch The Rock and John Cena
will get a fast and furious spin-off
also and Dave Batista will be the
villain Batista responded with two
nauseated emojis and the words thank you
for your consideration hashtag I'd
rather do good films now we love Batista
but that's a pretty bold response from a
man who has starred and not one but two
Escape Plan sequels besides those two
missteps however Batista has been fairly
choosy with most of his roles Never Say
Never but that big time dunk on Vin
Diesel's franchise will probably keep
the animal out of Fast and Furious films
for a while
it's almost impossible to think of roles
like James Bond or Han Solo in the hands
of different actors but these are just
two roles that could have been totally
unlike their present form imagine how
differently these Classics would be if
casting went the way the filmmakers
originally planned
Jurassic Park is such a well-crafted
movie it's hard to imagine anything
changing the effects hold up
surprisingly well decades later the
pacing is tight Jeff Goldblum is still
impossibly sexy it's a great film
however the lead role of Dr Alan Grant
who's played in the movie by Sam Neal
was originally offered to Harrison Ford
for reasons that are obvious if you
think about it Grant was a Gruff Rowdy
scientist paleontologist rather than
archaeologist in his case who could
effectively manage jungle territory
while pursued by a deadly enemy he even
had a cool floppy hat as effectively as
Sam Neil brought the character to life
we all know we'd throw money at a film
about Indiana Jones versus dinosaurs
unfortunately Ford saw it differently he
compared the idea to putting Indiana
Jones on Mars an idea that evidently
made more sense to him a decade and a
half later when they actually had
Indiana Jones meeting Spacemen you
jumped in a refrigerator to escape an
atomic bomb Ford you couldn't punch a
dinosaur
speaking of Harrison Ford he almost
never had a chance to perform either of
his most closely identified characters
the roles of Indiana Jones and Raiders
of the Lost Ark and Han Solo in the
first Star Wars film were originally
offered to Tom Selleck who turned them
both down
this actually made sense at the time
believe it or not the original draft of
Star Wars A New Hope imagined Han Solo
as much older than Luke Skywalker like a
kind of Black Sheep Uncle figure which
honestly could have been confusing with
all the other themes of familial
Connection in the film
by the time Raiders of the Lost Ark was
being filmed Ford had been in three of
George Lucas's films American Graffiti
and the first two Star Wars movies and
Lucas worried about becoming known for
reusing certain actors he gave Selleck
another shot but it didn't work out as
selek was already committed to his
series Magnum PI and the network
wouldn't let him take the film losing
out on Raiders was a particularly bitter
pill for Selleck who ended up cooling
his heels in Hawaii during an actor
strike while Indiana Jones and Company
were also on the island Selleck
explained with some regret I go to
Hawaii to start Magnum the actors go on
strike and I had given my deposit to a
landlady and I couldn't afford a
security deposit so I start working as a
handyman in Hawaii with no job and guess
who comes to Hawaii to finish their
movie Raiders of the Lost Ark so I could
have done them both
Matt Damon has turned down a lot of
major movie roles one of the most
surprising he almost played conflicted
paraplegic former Marine Jake Scully and
James Cameron's sprawling Sci-Fi Action
film Avatar the decision was tough on
Damon not only because he was a huge fan
of Cameron's but also because he figured
the star potential of the film could
encourage the actor who took his place
in this case Sam Worthington to
potentially take jobs from him in the
future
unfortunately scheduling conflicts got
in the way leaving us to imagine what
could have been what it is
possibly that's true I I there's I have
no defense for other than that there was
an actual scheduling conflict
While most of the Kill Bill movies
action follows the ultraviolent exploits
and tribulations of the vengeful bride
the character Bill looms large over both
films come on his name's right there in
the title
his particular cruelties obsessions and
motivations trickle through his assassin
minions and even the bride herself
all of which is to explain why when
Warren Beatty turned down the titular
role Quentin Tarantino was forced to do
a complete rewrite to compensate
Tarantino explained the Warren Beatty
thing is interesting because once I cast
David Carradine I did a lot of little
rewrites actually shifting that
character into David's sphere and it was
really interesting reading that first
draft because that's the Warren Beatty
version he's more of a James Bond type
character
it's honestly hard to imagine how that
film would have turned out it certainly
would have been a far cry from the
gritty Suburban Samurai film we wound up
seeing
once the James Bond producers dumped
Pierce Brosnan a few curious shoulders
were tapped looking to shake things up
and impressed with his Sharp Dressed
killer performance in American Psycho
producer Barbara Brockley had a meeting
with bale to offer him the role as
double 07. however Bale a British actor
himself was loathed to take on a role
that embodied what he considered the
worst British stereotypes all bundled
together he was reportedly cordial in
his refusal but at one point quipped
quote I've already played a serial
killer clearly he's not a fan
Nicholas Cage has turned down almost as
many memorable roles as he's taken is
how should we put this nicely curiously
varied career has led him all over the
map even when he wasn't searching for
national treasure among the many
interesting oddities on his resume he
turned down two roles that went to Keanu
Reeves Neo in The Matrix and the title
character in Constantine according to
cage he turned down the Matrix because
he wasn't interested in flying to
Australia to film it while he was
initially more enthusiastic about
Constantine he ended up departing the
project after original director tarsum
Singh dropped out sparking a pair of
lawsuits between Singh and the studio by
the time the dust settled Reeves was on
board
another actor considered for the role of
Neo in The Matrix was Will Smith and
although it ended up launching a
blockbuster Trilogy Smith seems really
at peace with turning down a massive
once in a lifetime role speaking to
wired he admitted that a project like
the Matrix is really difficult to sell
in a pitch and that when the movie was
first described to him quote he didn't
see it after watching the film later
Smith also felt Reeves was a better fit
saying I would have absolutely messed up
the Matrix
at that point I wasn't smart enough of
an actor to let the movie be whereas
Keanu was smart enough to let it be just
let the movie and the director tell the
story and don't try to perform every
moment however he doesn't quite have
that level of zen-like Peace about wild
wild west the film he accepted instead
of the Matrix although the movie was a
financial success critics tore it to
pieces and in hindsight he admits his
performance was a cash grab and led him
to vow never to take on a project again
just for the money he presumably made
his vow while reclining on a pile of
cash
oh
[Applause]
Al Pacino is possibly one of the
greatest actors that ever lived with a
career bringing to life some of the most
memorable characters in modern Cinema
which makes it even more incredible to
consider what might have been for any
number of roles naturally every director
wanted a piece of Pacino at his Peak
unfortunately he couldn't be everywhere
at once at various times he had the
potential to be Han Solo in Star Wars
Willard in Apocalypse Now Axel Foley
from Beverly Hills Cop John McLean from
die hard and even freaking Rambo instead
of being on a couple posters in your
college dorm room he could potentially
have been on all of them
through the 90s and into the early 2000s
the name Bruce Willis was synonymous
with Action Hero that's almost entirely
due to his role as John McLean a
wisecracking regular cop thrust into
extraordinary life or death situations
in a string of Die Hard films when the
original die hard hit theaters in 1988
Willis was seen as an unconventional if
not risky choice to headline a Full
Throttle action movie
at the time Willis was known almost
entirely for his emmy-nominated role as
cheeky private detective David Addison
on the TV rom-com Moonlighting according
to screenwriter Stephen E de Souza in
Die Hard in oral history filmmakers
hired Willis quote in desperation every
big Action Hero and tough guy actor of
the 80s passed on Die Hard including
Arnold Schwarzenegger Sylvester Stallone
James Khan Burt Reynolds and Richard
Gere
Deadpool marked a major comeback from
Ryan Reynolds whose once promising
career had been knocked off course by a
few bombs Chief among them the 2010 DC
Comics movie Green Lantern the superhero
adventure was both a critical and
Commercial failure earning back about
half its 200 million dollar budget at
the American box office Reynolds
explained to variety after Green Lantern
I was pretty much unhirable but while
his star was falling another guise was
Rising Jon Hamm the annually Emmy
nominated star of the AMC 1960s period
piece Mad Men seems to have dodged a big
green bullet as DC aggressively pursued
him to be a big screen superhero ham
told GQ they came after me pretty hard
for Green Lantern but I was like meh
that's not what I want to do
in the 1990s Leonardo DiCaprio was the
Boy Wonder of Hollywood finding fame
fortune and Teen Idol status with roles
like troubled teen Luke on Growing Pains
Jack Dawson and Titanic and Romeo and
bass lerman's Romeo and Juliet it only
makes sense that the fresh-faced box
office draw would be given the chance to
play actual Boy Wonder Robin AKA Dick
Grayson in Warner Brothers ongoing
Batman franchise in 2015 he told
shortlist that he was under
consideration for the part which would
have started with 1995's Batman Forever
saying I never screen tested I had a
meeting with Joel Schumacher it was just
one meeting and no I didn't end up doing
it as I recall I took the meeting but
didn't want to play the role DiCaprio
mentioned two other parts in big movies
that he met with filmmakers about before
taking himself out of contention Anakin
Skywalker and the Star Wars prequels and
Spider-Man in Spider-Man
in 1996 and 1997 Will Smith starred in
the back-to-back summer Blockbuster's
Independence Day and Men in Black
the movies marked His official
transition from sitcom star to Hollywood
a-lister with the Fresh Prince of Bel
Air having ended its run just weeks
before Independence Day hit theaters
I make this look good
Smith wasn't the first choice to play
rookie Agent J in Men In Black however
another actor known primarily for one
huge TV role was offered at first David
Schwimmer known to Millions as lovelorn
paleontologist Ross on Friends while he
was shooting the comedy the pallbearer
for Miramax the studio was so confident
the future box office bomb would be a
hit that it wanted to sign Schwimmer to
a three-movie deal Schwimmer agreed to
it if they let him also direct since
you've been gone and cast everyone from
his Chicago Theater Company the film
went into production and Schwimmer gave
all of his friends roles he explained on
the awards chatter podcast about a month
before production I get the call about
Men In Black which was a direct conflict
with directing that film I just said I
can't these are my closest friends in
the world this is their first shot at a
movie my first shot at directing nor
could he delay filming the movie in
favor of Men In Black because he'd be
due back at friends MIB producers had to
move on and they picked Smith
the Harry Potter films were perfectly
cast but it's still fun to look at what
might have been especially when it comes
to actors who decided to pass on the
chance to participate in such a huge
Blockbuster here are some actors who
decided that appearing in The Wizarding
franchise just wasn't for them
Ian McKellen is a legendary actor so it
makes sense that his name came up to
replace Richard Harris as Dumbledore in
the wake of Harris tragic death
following the second film however
McKellen turned down the role because he
thought it would have been inappropriate
as he explained people say to me don't
you wish you'd played Dumbledore I say
no I played Gandalf the original there
was a question as to whether I might
take over from Richard Harris but seeing
as one of the last things he did
publicly was say what a dreadful actor
he thought I was it would not have been
appropriate for me to take over his part
it would have been unfair he played
Dumbledore of course the wizard
I played the real wizard although
Michael Gambon eventually took over the
role for the rest of the series
McClellan still gets confused for the
character he told the telegraph in 2013.
the other day there were 100 people
outside the theater who wanted
autographs just as I did the last one a
woman grasped my hand and said it's so
wonderful to meet Dumbledore in person I
blew her a kiss and got into my car
Tilda Swinton was set to take on the
part of batty Professor Sybil treilani
but she ended up turning down the role
at the time it was reported that she
couldn't fit the film into her busy
schedule however some comments she's
made since then imply that she may have
actually had a much weirder reason in a
2016 interview with Scott's magazine
Swinton condemned boarding schools
Hogwarts included she called her own
experience at West Heath boarding school
in London a quote very lonely and
isolating environment she further
explained that's why I dislike films
like Harry Potter which tend to
romanticize such places I think they are
a very cruel setting in which to grow up
and I don't feel children benefit from
that type of education children need
their parents and the love parents can
provide Emma Thompson ended up with the
part and Swinton avoided having to
relive any bad memories
Hugh Grant was reportedly so prepared to
play the role of pompous defense against
the dark arts Professor gilderoy
Lockhart in Harry Potter and the Chamber
of Secrets that he went ahead and dyed
his hair blonde however he ended up
backing out to star in the romantic
comedy two weeks notice however Chamber
of Secrets director Christopher Columbus
contested these reports claiming that he
had never spoken to the actor about
doing the film regardless of what Grant
was or wasn't offered the part ended up
going to Kenneth Branagh who brought his
standard level of Gusto to the
performance Pulp Fiction actor Tim Roth
was forced to decide between Tim
Burton's 2001 Planet of the Apes remake
and the part of Severus Snape in Harry
Potter according to Roth he was offered
the role before Alan Rickman was but he
decided to turn it down so that he could
focus on Apes as he told MTV News in
2007 I was going to do both films we
rigged it so that I could fly back and
forth they figured out the schedule but
it just got to be overwhelming in my
mind my kids really liked the books they
were really into me doing it but the
idea of being an ape with Tim was too
good while Rickman was ultimately
incredible in the role Roth might have
been closer to how the books originally
described Snape Rickman was old for the
part at 55 when the first film was
released while Roth was only 38 based on
the book Snape should have been 31 when
Harry started at Hogwarts according to
Roth he would have played Snape very
differently but he ultimately believed
Rickman was the right man for the role I
didn't want my life to be franchised
Helen mcrory didn't miss out on the
Harry Potter films entirely but she was
kept from playing a much bigger part
than what she ended up with mcrory
ultimately played Narcissa Malfoy though
she was originally cast as narcissus
sister Bellatrix Lestrange that role
eventually went to Helena Bonham Carter
when mcrory got pregnant
just a boy As mcrory Told parade in 2011
I got pregnant with my first child and
insurance wouldn't cover pregnant
witches it was lovely that they invited
me back and wanted me to be a part of it
somehow this begs the question what are
the maternity leave policies at Hogwarts
and the rest of the Wizarding World
fans started pushing for author J.K
Rowling to appear in the Harry Potter
films as soon as they were announced but
the writer says she's better off behind
the camera Rowling told the Sunday mail
that producers offered her the chance to
play Harry's mom Lily but she ultimately
turned him down as she put it I really
am not cut out to be an actress even one
who just has to stand and wave I would
have messed it up somehow while
Geraldine Somerville did a great job as
Lily we're sure fans would have loved
rolling in the part too even if she did
mess it up it would have been a thrill
to see a beloved author do a cameo
foreign